earlier when you were referencing that
the buddhist may emphasize emptiness and
then someone else may emphasize pure
consciousness and someone else may
emphasize love and so on and so on are
these all unified in some manner
they're unified in this and they're all
coming from
the same place
but not unified you see some
advaita vedantiform they think they're
unified because they're all
consciousness they're all consciousness
and all you know
manifestative consciousness and that
emptiness is
one of the manifestation of
consciousness we just would disagree
with that will think consciousness
arises out
of emptiness you see
my understanding of it
is that the actual truth is
indeterminate
just like quantum theory until you
experience it
it's not set
when people want to want the certainty
or the security
of feeling the
truth of what i am
is here and i just need to discover it
that is how many spiritual teachings say
it is here you just need to open up
waken up to it
and my what i discovered through my
exploration is that
the truth is here but not manifest
it's not just a matter of discovering it
i need to be ready and interested and
open and then it will appear
where will it come from
it doesn't come from anywhere
it just comes
it just appears
so what what is that what do we say
where does it come from
i say it's unknown unknowable